ça va durer combien de temps tout
ça Syvie la vie d'une grande Vette de la
chanson française doit être une vie bien
remplie existe-t-il une petite place
pour les animaux une grande place parce
que à chaque retour d'abord celui-ci là
il est il fait partie des voyages parce
que je l'emmène un peu partout dans la
mesure du possible et puis il est
pratique il est petit et puis il suit
partout le chat c'est un petit peu plus
sauvage mais comme vous voyez ils sont
ils s'entendent bien tous les deux c'est
un chat que j'ai recueilli dans mon
jardin qui est venu tout petit comme ça
sa mère l'a l'a apporté chez nous et
puis petit à petit on l'a apprivoisé et
puis j'étais la première à pouvoir
l'attraper alors maintenant ça y est il
est adopté alors il y a le chat le chien
enfin les chiens mon premier animal
c'était un un lapin un lapin blanc qui
ressemblait un peu à snif il faisait
office de de chien de poupée il était
dans dans les dans les poussettes
il était vraiment adorable ce lapin puis
j'ai eu deux bergers allemands Cali et
Ringo j'ai eu un petit yorkcheer que
j'ai perdu dans des
conditions très tristes il y a 6 mois
qui était mon chien en fait qui qui me
suivait partout et on s'adorait tous les
deux on avait nos hab habitude ça
faisait 7 ans que je l'avais et puis le
le tout dernier celui-ci là qui est un
bébé de 9 mois qui a sommeil et qui qui
veut rien
entendre il est en photo sur votre sur
la pochette de votre dernier disque
est-ce que vos fans ont écrit à son
sujet ah oui oui j'ai j'ai des demand en
mariage il va être content il va avoir
plein de fiancé mais j'ai j'ai rarement
vu des chiens comme ça euh en France et
et
j'ai j'ai rapporté de New York une une
petite chienne et alors ils vont
certainement se marier l'année prochaine
en fait ils vont avoir des des bébés et
puis il adore son chat alors là depuis
que le chat est arrivé c'est c'est
devenu c'est devenu l'amour entre les
deux ils sont absolument accroqués on
dirait un dessin animé on peut rire
c'est ce qui est de formidable avec les
animaux c'est que d'abord on n'est
jamais seul parce qu'ils sont ils sont
toujours là ils sont toujours à vous
faire la fête à vous attendre à alors le
chat n'est pas un chat parce que il a
pris les les manières du chien il a
l'air très sage comme
ça qui va manger
dan mais
non voilà cri viens
cri viens viens le chat non c'est pas
pour toi c'est pour cri
cri bien bien alors il lèche le chien
pend des heures et puis alors il ne
griffe jamais il a des pâtes d'œuv lourd
et puis il prend des manières du chien
il mort par exemple SIF sniff
sniff
mais allez viens viens
snifou ça va durer combien de temps tout
ça combien de temps ça va durer
monsieur bon je vais faire le
mort quel caractère a-t-il oh alors là
il est infernal il n'obéit pas aucune
obéissance mais il est très gay il est
très affectueux il est très
joueur
[Musique]
apporte des boules de
neige
[Musique]
j'ai j'ai d'autres chiens qui vivent à
la campagne parce qu'ils sont qui sont
plus gros j'ai le chien de mon frère qui
s'appelle Watson qui a son son caractère
alors ils ont tous des surnoms alors
Watson c'est la vache
Blanchette c'est un chien de chasse mais
il na jamais été à la chasse et puis il
est très peureux viens là VI là le chien
et alors il a ses petites manières c'est
lui le plus obéissant encore des de tous
les trois chiens gentil gentil gentil
gentil puis a Gustave Le le le petit
noir qui est un bâtard qu'on a eu tout
petit disons c'est le le chien de Johnny
et tous les deux avec Watson ce sont des
campagnards alors on est obligé de faire
un système de SAS quand on arrive à la
campagne parce qu'entre le chat le chien
qui habite à Paris et les deux autres
qui habitent à la campagne qui sont
assez solitaires il y a des jalousies
qui se créent je ve dire que toute la
famille est très habituée à fermer les
portes fermez les portes Watson est là
vous avez fermé les faire entrer snif
oui alors tout ça est très bien organisé
dans cette
maison les chiens ont ce côté tellement
innocents et tellement dépendant de leur
maître et
et et c'est ce qui a de plus touchant en
fait c'est c'est comme les petits
enfants c'est comme tout ce qui est
comme ça vulnérable et
tout à fait dépendant de vous c'est
c'est très touchant je veux dire on se
sent tout à fait responsable d'eux
comme ils sont tellement
[Musique]
gentil